[Music]
the wait is almost over for the Real
Housewives of New York City season 10
returns tomorrow night on Bravo and
Michelle you were just with the most
well regal housewife of all yeah yeah
we'll go with regal Cameron we're
talking about countess LuAnn de Lesseps
and we have got three reasons why she is
the one to watch this season did I ever
think going into season ten that I was
gonna get arrested I mean yeah why need
no storyline
I don't leave it just happens to me I've
been traveling I've been to prison and I
just fresh from jail and a stint in
rehab the 52 year old is back and ready
to face her fellow housewives she called
me a convict LuAnn was arrested on
Christmas Eve for public intoxication
and resisting arrest
the charges are still pending and she
could face up to five years in prison it
was an out of control moment for me and
I don't like to be out of control I'm
the woman that's not out of control
another reason to watch LuAnn she's
still reeling from her short-lived
seven-month marriage to Tom D'Agostino
do you have a biggest regret getting
married after you find somebody's
cheated on you is probably my biggest
why did I do that exactly still she's
not afraid to put herself out there
[Music]
her outrageous cabaret show sold out
after superfan Jennifer Lawrence freaked
out over her on watch what happens live
I had no idea of the magnitude of how
big of a fan she was first of all in how
surprised she was after the surprise on
Andy Show she was helping me with my tag
lines for season 10
[Music]
[Applause]